it's not polite to talk about brown and
black people dying because rich white
people in America feel better about
themselves when the browner black people
don't get to use DDT I'm Katherine
Maggie award for recent TV and I'm here
today with Andrew Morris co-editor of a
new volume Silent Spring at 50 Andrew
thanks for being with us thanks for
having me tell me a little bit about
Rachel Carson who wrote the
environmentalist classic Silent Spring
50 years ago and why you felt like it
was time to take her on that well we
start with why we thought we should take
her on now it's the 50th anniversary of
the book that many people think founded
modern American environmentalism it
shifted the emphasis from conservation
to a more radical view of man outside of
nature and that's a view that continues
to dominate the American environmental
movement
we knew there would be a lot of a lot of
Tory things said about this and so we
wanted to give a more critical
assessment of it what do you think is
one area where Rachel Carson who
obviously is responsible for the
limiting of the use of DDT radically in
both in the United States and eventually
internationally what are some of the the
costs that her work has imposed that
people tend to overlook well the most
important cost comes from the limit on
the use of DDT and malaria control
Carson spent 250 pages talking about the
dangers of chemical used specifically
DDT used and created this marvelous
image of a Silent Spring where no birds
sang and scared the hell out of people
the result of that is millions and
millions of poor people in Africa and
Asia and Latin America died of malaria
and that's an enormous cost that
environmentalists don't ever want to
talk about in her discussion of DDT did
she have a point about the the ways that
it was being used or misused or did she
just screw the pooch on this one
entirely she was absolutely right about
one thing and that's that there were
massive subsidized spraying programs
going on in which the US Department of
Agriculture was blanketing the country
with not just DDT but other insecticides
in some very ill-considered
rain programs to control agricultural
pests and those programs paid no
attention to
property rights and out of that came
some well justified lawsuits against the
USDA which failed in which the courts
ruled that private property rights have
to get out of the way when the public
interest is at stake and surely if the
USDA is doing it then the public
interest is at stake and so she was
right about that we shouldn't have been
subsidizing a massive spring of people's
property against their will but that's
about the only thing she was right about
what charges can we ultimately lay at
Rachel Carson's door I mean I know that
doing a sort of strict death toll might
be an exaggeration but can you just kind
of give a quick point by point of you
know what are the changes that we can
trace pretty directly to Silent Spring
and and to what are the hopes for
reversing those or otherwise limiting
the damage well I I think the three
things that we should worry about and we
have chapters that address all these ARS
one is really is the death toll people
don't want to talk about it it's not
polite to talk about brown and black
people dying because rich white people
in America feel better about themselves
when the brown of black people don't get
to use DDT but that's that's the fact of
it we have denied other countries the
ability to use the single most effective
tool to stop malaria and so those
millions and millions of deaths I think
can be clearly laid at the door of
Silent Spring the second is that Carson
really was an advocate for
nationalization of environmental policy
and I think we can trace the
environmental movement that grew out of
Silent Spring really had an impact on
moving environmental policy out of the
state level to the federal level and
that's really been a cost we lost a lot
of flexibility and a lot of ability to
adapt to local conditions of that and
the third thing is that she was a big
pusher for this balance of nature idea
and that's not how conservation
biologists think about things today we
have a excellent chapter in the book by
a conservation biologist who points out
that that the whole balance of nature
the circle of life this is not the way
that biologists think about things but
that idea is firmly embedded in the
public psyche in part because of Rachel
Carson who are the who are the heirs of
Rachel Carson well the heirs of Rachel
Carson are the national environmental
organizations that want to control our
lives
Carson advocated a variety of
precautionary measures nothing should be
used without extensive testing she's the
she's in some sense the godmother of the
precautionary principle I don't think
there is regional carcinoma today and
that none of the modern environmental
writers write nearly as well as Rachel
Carson and none of them had the skill
and ability that she had or the moral
authority that she had they wish they
were Rachel Carson the the interesting
question would be what would have
happened if Rachel Carson had not died
of cancer she's not quite as radical as
some of her followers are and it's her
timely death in that sense saved them
from her ever having to reconsider some
of the ideas that she put forward in the
book and since she was a scientist I
think I'd like to think that maybe what
better information came along she would
have paid attention to it thank you very
much for speaking with Reason TV this is
andrew morris co-editor of violence
bring at fifty four reason TV i'm
katherine bengi ward
you